[Música]
Rafael War noc senador por el partido
demócrata resultó triunfador en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones de
mitad determinó del estado de Georgia
estamos hablando de Estados Unidos de
esta forma se consolida entonces la
mayoría demócrata en la cámara alta del
Congreso estadounidense y también como
lo decíamos despeja un poco más el
margen de maniobra para el gobierno del
presidente Joe biden en directo a vamos
Entonces hasta la ciudad de Washington
Allí se encuentra Cristóbal Vázquez
nuestro corresponsal para analizar y
complementar información relacionada con
este tema Cristóbal muy buenas noches y
ya lo decíamos con este resultado
Entonces qué tanto margen de maniobra de
maniobra van a tener los demócratas en
la cámara alta que análisis se puede
hacer buenas noches
Buenas noches en la cámara alta quedan
con 51 votos los demócratas es decir ya
no va a ser necesaria la figura de
kamala Harris como voto de desempate no
va a tener que estar constantemente
yendo al congreso a Capitolio a tener
que pues desempatar recordemos que en
los primeros dos años del gobierno de
Joe biden 50 sillas en el senado eran
para demócratas 50 para republicanos
kamala era el voto de desempate ahora
cámara entonces va a poder tener mucho
margen de maniobra mucho más margen de
maniobra para enfocarse sobre todo en lo
que viene que es la campaña de
reelección de Joe biden que en las
próximas semanas anunciará el presidente
y enfocarse en otros proyectos sobre
todo en temas migratorios que ella está
encargada precisamente del tema
migratorio en Estados Unidos imagen de
maniobra también para los demócratas en
el congreso porque pues dejan de
depender de yo manche en un senador que
aunque es demócrata ha votado por
republicanos o al menos para obstruir
los proyectos demócratas de la
administración de Joe biden imagen de
maniobra también porque al tener 51
escaños 51 sillas en el senado Pues en
los comités es mucho más fácil aprobar
los jueces aprobar las personas que han
nombrado que los republicanos han
querido frenar a probar proyectos de ley
y aprobar también investigaciones que
son claves también de Cara a los
próximos dos años que se viene teniendo
en cuenta obviamente que la cámara de
representantes es decir la cámara baja
es de mayoría republicana Así que ahí va
a haber un choque de trenes en el
legislativo un choque de trenes algo que
ya se ha presentado en el pasado en el
legislativo de Estados Unidos en una o
en otra de las cámaras de las dos que Lo
componen hablemos ahora de el rival
Cristóbal el republicano herschel Walker
que es un protegido de Donald Trump
perdió en esta lección En esta segunda
vuelta en Georgia que dice Esto entonces
para los conservadores y también para el
ex mandatario para el presidente Donald
Trump
Pues es que ya muchos analistas
republicanos en Muchos medios nacionales
decían que pues era un poco
impresentable que el partido republicano
tuviera un candidato como
acusado de haber financiado el aborto de
varias de las mujeres con las que se
metió pero en campaña estar diciendo que
iba en contra del aborto era provida y
apoyaba esta iniciativa de restringir El
aborto en Estados Unidos Aunque en su
vida personal financiaba y empujaba a
las mujeres con las que se metía a
abortos además eran impresentable el
hecho de que él pues vive en Texas él no
vive Ni siquiera en Georgia y se
presentó en Georgia porque vio un
espacio ahí teniendo en cuenta que
además es afroamericano que tenía el
apoyo de Donald Trump de poder quedarse
con ese segundo escaño de Georgia hay
que recordar que Georgia pues es el
primer estado entonces en Estados Unidos
en elegir un afroamericano y un judío al
mismo tiempo en la cámara alta pero pues
obviamente esto deja mucho que desear
para el partido mexicano mucho que
desear pero
en el tema de El senado porque en cuanto
a el gobernador en cuanto a senado
estatal en cuanto a la gobernación
Estatal la mayoría sigue siendo
republicana es decir ahí hay todavía un
poder republicano importante pero que se
han dado cuenta ya los republicanos que
es importante tener en cuenta que para
poder ganar en algún cargo político sea
a nivel Estatal o nacional pues no es
necesario la política y no es necesario
afianzarse y alinearse a las políticas
de Donald Trump es decir lo que los
republicanos se han dado cuenta en este
momento y sobre todo en esta elección Es
que para poder llegar algún cargo
público pues no es del todo necesario
tener que tener el respaldo de Donald
Trump que pues ya se empieza entonces
del partido republicano a a tomar un
paso acostado a querer dar Un paso atrás
de el apoyo de Donald Trump porque ven
como lo ven en esta elección que pues
simplemente no resultado del partido
seguir Aliado a las políticas de Trump
si quieren seguir ganando poder en
Estados Unidos Cristóbal brevemente
Entonces el estado de Georgia como tal
queda como nuevo estado púrpura de Cara
a esas elecciones del 2024
sí es un estado púrpura definitivamente
Y aunque lo mencionado Así es decir el
gobernador republicano si el senado
Estatal es republicano sí Muchos jueces
siguen siendo republicanos a nivel
nacional Georgia y sobre todo en las
áreas urbanas es un estado demócrata
entonces empieza a tasarse entonces la
diferencia entre los votos en el área
rural versus los votos demócratas en el
área urbana y de cara precisamente a las
elecciones del 2024 de selecciones
presidenciales la presencia demócrata en
las áreas Rurales como Sabana como
Atlanta como Columbia vas a ser muy
importantes para poder el partido
demócrata pues seguir al mando de El
Ejecutivo es decir cuatro años más en la
Casa Blanca